[Music]
and now the premiere of a lifetime
original mini movie
a recipe for seduction starts now
my body can't take it yes you heard it
right there is a lifetime movie where
mario lopez plays colonel sanders
i mean what are you going to do it's not
like you can find another colonel right
being a huge fan of kfc it's vader
looking good
mario lopez my dad oh well he's in the
army he's a major
i mean uh colonel
i was like i need to see this and boy is
it a glorious dumpster fire that
immediately made me order a family
bucket and eat it entirely by myself
so strap yourselves in for what's sure
to be an instant holiday classic
i present to you a recipe for seduction
this pipe in hot love affair of deep
fried romantic goodness is presented by
kentucky fried chicken so you know it's
gonna be good when right off the bat the
movie itself
is presented by kentucky fried chicken
registered trademark and i haven't seen
product placement this egregious since
toyota basically bought an entire
episode of bones to show off its new car
how'd you do that it's called
intelligent parking assist the car
guides itself into the parking spot does
it solve murders you'll also notice the
director here has one name
gene or it could be fancy like jean but
if you go to imdb you'll see the movie
actually has
three directors and i'm like why does a
16 minute long movie need
three directors yes you heard it right
this finger licking masterpiece is only
16 minutes long which means it'll
probably not get nominated for an oscar
and the oscar goes
to a recipe for seduction i sure do have
a lot of nightmares about chicken
welcome to the mancera home where
everyone is enjoying the staple
christmas meal of kfc
actually when i was doing research for
this video and yes i had to do research
for this video
i found out that in japan apparently
it's a tradition to order kfc at
christmas
damn they are always one step ahead of
us
christmas so everyone
is enjoying what is obviously a
christmas themed dinner
the entire house is adorned in christmas
decorations even though
christmas is never mentioned once in the
story because you know the war on
christmas
that boy he looked me right in the eyes
he said
happy holidays
they're all enjoying the fabulous
chicken made by the mincera's new chef
sexy colonel sanders it's my new chef
he's incredibly talented but the real
drama happens when billy
garibaldi iii yes that's his name the
quintessential entitled douchebag
proposes to
jessica and jessica isn't having it i
need some time to think
this sparks the ire of jessica's mom
bunny whose husband has left their
family in massive debt
and jessica's marriage to billy would
help them out of it
your father left us nothing but a legacy
of debt your father left us nothing but
a legacy of bad debts do you know what
this marriage would mean for us
it will ensure our survival it's also
just funny that billy is the name of the
actor who played the villain in titanic
and i just know too much about that
movie
jessica is introduced to harlan the
family's resident chef who lives in the
guest house
harland was head chef at libti that
translates to small
grapefruit he worked at a restaurant
called small grapefruit of course
jessica is totally smitten by the
colonel's good looks and fried chicken
energy emanating from his glistening
biceps
she even ignores a call from billy
naturally the colonel and jessica go on
a romantic walk around the grounds where
she asks him what his story is
but with the author of it i'd have a
chapter in there about my secret recipe
changing the world
a secret recipe but all this talk of
changing the world is
interrupted by billy you humiliated me
rejecting me in front of my parents oh
take it easy okay slow down there billy
you just can't come walting down here
wearing that pink sweater and think i'm
not going to comment on it he completely
rails on jessica for disrespecting him
and even tears into the colonel beat it
crouton get back to the kitchen and let
me in my fiancee
stop you did not just say that is this
how you're gonna talk to the man that
made that delicious fried chicken you
loved
the chicken is delicious anyways you
know the colonel isn't gonna take it
don't call me crouton billy tells
jessica that he knows they're meant to
be together and not to turn this into
the biggest mistake
of her life but later jessica confides
in her gay best friend lee
that she thinks she's falling in love
with the colonel i mean come on who
wouldn't
i think i'm falling for the new chef
harland
oh jessica you've talked to him for two
minutes so
jessica's mom sneaks into her room while
she's taking a shower and
texts billy using jessica's phone to say
where she is
she needs to talk to him it's a bit
weird because jessica will know when she
looks at her phone that someone else
sent this message but
anyway bunny ends up meeting billy at
the country club because you know that's
where all these things happen
to tell him that jessica is falling for
harland not only that but
harlan claims to have some secret recipe
that'll make him
a man of great repute yeah this is like
the colonel sanders origin story where
he hasn't fully perfected his recipe yet
although i would have much preferred a
story about the colonel coming back from
war with ptsd and a heart incapable of
love that only a woman and sweet sweet
fried chicken could overcome but hey
look i'm not writing these things
up next we have one of the biggest
bombshells of the movie bunny has been
sleeping with billy and if they want to
continue their weird mother's son-in-law
romp
billy better find a way to get rid of
the colonel we all have our secrets
really you remember our long weekend in
the vineyard
how could i forget that's hot if you
marry my daughter
i promise there'll be more long weekends
in your future
as many as you want
first of all i'm like why can't bunny
fire harlan
she was the one who hired him why does
she need billy to get rid of him
and wait till you find out how much
billy is willing to pay harlan to leave
while snooping around the kitchen billy
finds harlan's secret recipe
secret's out chicken man well it's not
the full recipe just yet you see the
colonel
is still perfecting it but when harlan
catches billy in the kitchen
billy offers him half a million dollars
to leave and i'm like
everybody get the card
half a million to leave i'd be like uh
jessica who unbeknownst to bunny
jessica's best friend was on a date and
overheard her little convo with billy
and he's come to tell
jessica the truth i know what i saw and
i'm telling jessica
of course bunny can't let that happen
and in true lifetime fashion
bonks him in the back of the head
colonel sanders confronts jessica about
billy thinking that it was her who told
him about his secret recipe
my secret recipe that that was supposed
to stay between us
i never told him about that harlan
what's going on but jessica professes
her love to him
i don't want billy i want you with bunny
realizing things are out of control the
next morning she tells jessica that
harlan mysteriously left in a hurry
in the middle of the night and jessica
is saddened by this news taking a walk
on the grounds when she hears a noise
coming from the shed that's right
billy has tied up harland he's ruining
everything
billy mom thank god billy has gone crazy
and when bunny joins the party
jessica finds out she's in on it too
there's just one problem remember that
best friend bunny knocked
out well he's escaped of course and just
when billy is about to put an end to the
kernel
another whack to the back of the head
bunny is just not having it
this is all your fault i mean look at
this not exactly sure what she's trying
to achieve here but
jessica pushes her mom into a plastic
shelf and our couple is finally safe
and reunited where one year later they
get married now are you set for this
shocking ending that sets up a sequel
i know you don't care but i'm gonna tell
you anyway jessica's mom is at some sort
of psych hospital where she's visited by
billy and this is what he says as he
eats a delicious piece of kfc
i found them
like are the colonel and jessica hiding
is this supposed to be some sort of
surprise
i personally think it would have been
cooler if he found out what the secret
recipe was and he was secretly working
for a chick-fil-a or something
lifetime call me i am totally ready to
write the sequel and you can pay me in
fried chicken thanks for watching
everyone if you liked the video be sure
to like subscribe and share and
check out my worst tv and films playlist
with tons of other content just like
this
for more bad takes you can always follow
me on twitter and instagram at
thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much